so let's start from the top some of
these are familiar some
less so let's have a look at this one at
the top
if i presented this to you and said
please integrate that right
what is your first thought as you look
at it don't worry about the actual
answer just
tell me what your thought process is
difference between two squares thank you
now in this case i've given you an
obvious example
right a quadratic that is there's a nice
name behind the factorization
but it's just the fact that it can be
factorized right if i had just easily
given you something like this
my good old favorite quadratic
expression there right even though it's
not difference of squares
in the same way you can factorize that
denominator and then once you factorize
it what can you do
we can do partial fractions right just
like we did before okay so my thought
here is my thought is
if it's a denominator that can be
factorized
if the denominator is quadratic but it
can be factorized
then we're pretty much good to go in
terms of using partial fractions okay
and that happens a lot
so this is the first sort of class
if you like of quadratic denominators
that you're going
to encounter if the dominator can be
factorized
then go ahead split it apart into
partial fractions
i'm slightly lazy here i'm even just
going to write like the primitive will
come out of
well it'll be something like a on in
this case x minus 1
b on x plus 1. dx you're going to get
some logs
and then off you go so this is the first
category right and it's the easiest
these second two they both come in the
context of extension one
now if we were just extension 1 students
you could look at these and say well
what else can i do with these i've got a
handy dandy reference sheet which
actually helps me here which i'll get in
a second okay
but you are not extension 1 students you
well you are not just extension 1
students you have all this other stuff
that's floating around here so here is
my way of determining
what these actually equal to when you've
got these other ones to mix them up with
look carefully with me at this first one
i think it's the easiest to recognize
look at that denominator for a second
it's all about the denominator right can
someone tell me
what kind of shape is that if i just ask
you to focus on the denominator what
shape is that
that's a semi-circle it's not just any
serpent circle it's the
unit semi-circle it's the top part
anyway okay now for me when i think of
the unit circle
in stage six i think trigonometry this
is my mental cue
to say oh this is an inverse trig
primitive right that's where i'm going
to land okay this first one
on the unit circle what are the two
coordinates that we have for the x and
the y
what what do we use when we put in a
parameter of theta
so sine and cos right sine and cos
not tan so therefore what you're going
to get here
is in fact i can write it all the way
over here on the right hand side i'm
going to get
sine inverse of x plus a constant
right the unit circle that was my
that was my mental cue that denominator
looks a whole lot
like the unit circle and that's what
prompts me to remember oh sine and
cosine actually don't have on the
reference sheet i don't have a result
for cosine because just a shifted
version of this
right of cos inverse so that's me
remembering that it's going to be
sine inverse when you have a look at the
third one
right one plus x squared again
mentioning to you that this is in the
context of extension one that should
signal to you oh it's the other
inverse trig one which is tan
so we can write a head on the go ahead
and write on the right hand side it's
going to be
10 inverse but for me my mental cue is
this is something which unlike the first
one which i can turn into partial
fractions
and i like the second one which has that
reminder of the unit circle
that doesn't look like the unit circle
to me it isn't right i mean it's a
parabola moved up a little bit
um the denominator anyway and i can't
factorize it either
right so the denominator can't be
factorized
and it doesn't give me that other q so
that's what tells me
i'm still in this if you have a look at
the similarity between
these two denominators here they both
got the one and the x squared in that
order
that's what tells me i'm still in
inverse tree gland
now just as i mentioned before and it's
worth noting down um because these are
still extension one results you have the
benefit
of the reference sheet telling you what
these results
actually are so if you want to see what
it looks like i've got it here
there you go make a bit smaller because
i've gone over the top of other things
this is what you'll see on sorry i make
a bit smaller there you go
this is what you'll see on the reference
sheet right now what you will notice i
hope
is that this is the souped-up version
the generalized version of handling sine
inverse
and tan inverse because if you have a
look here um
you don't always get a one here right
you could get any square number or even
if you get something like
three you're going to end up with the
square root of three over here right
also we can do more than just a sine
inverse of x you can do sine inverse of
any function this is including the
reverse chain rule in there as well
okay so what i wanted to do here i'm
giving you purposefully
these simplified versions here so you
can focus on which family of functions
do you end up with is it sign inverse
is a tan inverse and this is how you
modify from there okay
all right have a look down at this
fourth one
on the table have a think about your
starter questions right
what is your mental cue that tells you
where you can go
with this emanuel uh
x equals to square root k tangent theta
oh can you say that again one more time
x equals two square root k
tangent theta square root k
times tangent under the square root or
not on the screen
on the outs like this yes
and where does your brain go next after
that um
and i just because if you if you if you
square that one thing
you can differentiate it first so you
get eggs
and something and the debater
then you can suck this thing back into
the x and you will got uh
uh if you simplify you you've got uh
square root k
times c theta they can cancel out
okay okay so so i've been teaching
because i've been teaching maths for a
while now i usually get to anticipate
even when someone has something from
left field i'm like oh yeah i could see
that coming for example
veren completely ruined my lesson plan
the other day by the option i had which
i was going to tell you about third
he said first i was like well great okay
i'm gonna i'll run with it it's fine
okay
this one i'm actually not 100 following
yet so i'm going to i'm going to park
this idea i'm just going to pop it in
here so i can remember to come back
to it i want you to think back to your
starter questions
just to make sure we're all on the same
page right that result over there in the
integrand
does it look familiar when you have a
look at your starter questions which
question did we have a look at that
landed us on something like this pahan
are you just stretching you'll give me
the answer you wanna give me the answer
it's right it's the ln thing right have
a look at question two you start a
question right
we dif i handed you a function we
differentiate it from memory
the function was something like log of
x plus a square root of i think i gave
you guys x squared
minus seven x y minus seven um in fact
it can be
well i'll i'm gonna put a plus or minus
in there
hopefully you notice as you went through
that differentiation actually really
didn't matter
what that seven was it could have been
eight or nine or pi or e
it could have been minus as well that
never came in because
that constant right there doesn't affect
your inside derivative so that's why
i've put this plus or minus k in there
when you differentiate this you land
here right
if you differentiate this you get this
so it stands to reason again thinking
back to advanced right
if i reverse this process if i take this
and
integrate i should land back where i
started that's my primitive right
so with one minor modification i'll have
this log
right i have the x plus the square root
of
x squared whatever was underneath there
what's the one difference
because i'm integrating now this oh yes
that's true that's true i need my
constant integration there's another
difference
absolute value thank you absolute values
by the way
um i i mentioned it before um but i
artfully forgot to put on your canvas
page after this i'm going to be putting
like why those absolute value signs are
there is a really important question for
you to answer as extension 2 students
and just saying the logs are positive
doesn't cut it so i'm going to put that
link in please remind me someone
afterwards if i forget
okay we're most of the way down here
yeah questions just
asking isn't it that formula used to be
uh
yes that's a good question so excuse me
morgan is correct um actually you know
what can i hit pause on that question
only because as a it is a long and
interesting answer
a long and interesting answer that i do
know i'm happy to share with you but
maybe not
at this exact time in this lesson maybe
after we get people going
but remind me okay old table of standard
intercourse all right
can you please compare this fifth one
here with the quadratic denominator
just compare it to all the other ones
previous to that
have a think at what distinguishes this
and this is a tricky question to answer
but what distinguishes this one
from all of the previous ones emmanuel
what do you say
yeah you cannot factorize it as long as
you can't see it
and if you cannot factorize it in the
completing square okay so
i did mention this and it's even on your
page right um the syllabus itself says
integrate rational functions involving a
quadratic genre by
completing the square this is the kind
of question or this is the kind of
integrand
they're talking about i want to
highlight to you why can you look back
up at the four
rational functions above the thing that
stands out to me is none of them have
linear terms
in the denominator can you see that
there's never an x term there's an x
squared there's a constant term there's
never an x
okay so therefore as we've so often done
in maths we want to try and turn a
problem
that's weird looking into one that we're
more familiar with
these will always turn into something
like what you see
up above so long as you can let's write
the note together
complete the square right so
what we're going to do just as an
example right
is we will end up with something like 1
over
and then you know if if i'd given you
something monic over here
then i guess you would have something
like x plus k or squared
plus some other thing i don't know l
squared
with respect to x this is what we get
after completing the square and then
there's this extra bit hanging on the
end right
but we can deal with this we can deal
with this in the same way that we did
dealt with all the previous ones right i
guess this particular one looks like it
would turn
into a tan inverse right if
i threw in a square root down here like
so
i can still deal with it it's going to
be a log of some kind
right so the completing the square turns
this thing which is just a shifted
version
of all the previous ones into something
we're all already familiar with
okay so last one and then i'm actually
going to do
i'll see how we go for time i'm sort of
being a bit rude um
when you get something like this in the
integrand where you've got the square
root of
an entire rational function okay now
i want you to think for a second if you
saw something like this
if you saw something like this in your
nine or ten right even with in the
absence of a question
right i would think most of you would
instinctively say
i'm going to rationalize this
denominator and we extended that idea
when we went into complex numbers and we
said we can realize
denominators right now it turns out that
the reason we do that is so that
for instance if i had something like
this oh i don't know
right once i rationalize both those
denominators they can they can play ball
right and it's it's exactly the same
reason with complex denominators that's
why we realized so that those two can
interact with each other but i want you
to have a look up here right
and have a think about why maybe that's
actually less of a useful
thing i mean you can rationalize a
denominator if you want
but in the same way as you get a first
derivative should you factorize or
should you expand
well depends on what you're doing next
the thing we're doing next is
integrating have a look on the sheet
uh is there any problem with having an
irrational
denominator no we can actually deal with
them quite comfortably right
is there a problem with having an
irrational numerator
and the answer is yes there is because
if it's irrational
like this right you can't use say for
example your partial fractions you can't
break things apart
because everything's underneath the
square root you're like gross
right so this is me trying to explain to
you why here's your thought right
in cases like this almost always rather
than rationalizing the denominator which
has been our instinct for
years now when you're integrating
rationalizing the numerator
that's a messy looking m
rationalizing the numerator is almost
always a much more useful
thing to do for example if i took this
uh
this function over here had some
arbitrary u and v
and i went to rationalize the numerator
what would i multiply the top and bottom
by
think carefully i'm just trying to
rationalize and it's just the square
root of
u of x on the top so to rationalize i
guess i would multiply by the country in
a way right
i'm just going to multiply by the square
root of that function on the top u of x
now what that will give me is i'm going
to be integrating
square root of u times the square root
of u will just give me
u is that okay now on the denominator
you may get something
that looks messy right because the
square root of u times the square root
of v
is the square root of u times v and then
i'm integrating on that with respect to
x
but you so often i mean we are
interested in giving you questions you
can actually solve
you also frequently get in that
denominator a quadratic
underneath the square root then this
turns into one of these other kinds of
problems does that make sense
so therefore rationalize the numerator
not something we're used to
but that is probably the most useful
thing to do